[Applause]
investigators say that the 4.5 million
diamond ring stolen from kim kardashian
will most likely be
made into smaller less valuable stones
you know like
kendall and kylie
kim kardashian has debuted a new line of
body makeup
and she hyped it up by tweeting this
video of gloop
being laboriously trowelled onto her
skin
perfect for anyone with a job where you
don't wear pants
or touch any furniture it's a good
comeback story right
seabiscuit the mighty ducks robert
downey jr
rocky yes kim kardashian kim well
in the video she gets she just come on
her back i think
kim's body makeup raised a lot of
questions mainly does it come with this
manservant who does the application for
you
oh jeffreys don't forget the back of my
knees and my
underbutt but telling women that doing
their face isn't enough now they need to
slather their whole bodies is a little
harsh
there's no way people are going to fall
for and it's already completely sold out
i'd rather plant poison ivy plants in my
anus
before hearing another word about kim
kardashian go ahead and do that
please a guy told me that
i don't know if you've heard this bruce
jenner is going to go back
maybe to being a man
did you hear that that's an odd thing
because i remember him of course as a
woman
so it's hard for me to picture what he'd
even look like
as a man i remember because i'm from
canada so i remember he was in the 72
olympics
and he he won the he won the the
decathlon you know which is the the best
athlete in the world
was a woman and we didn't know at the
time because he kept a secret
but i remember they put the gold medal
around his
[ __ ] big juicy tits
and that to me is when they should have
he should just go i'm a lady and then
that would have been good for the lgbt
the community you know the community i
don't know if you've been over
seeing them and [ __ ] but it's a nice
community
and it would have been good all the lgbt
i tried to be inclusive of all the
letters
in the alphabet
but you know then he but he waited
that's the problem he waited till
65 that's when bruce jenner decided to
tell us he was a lady
now i don't know about you guys but to
me
is there really that much difference
between a 65 year old
at some point you got to realize
you're just some old thing nobody wants
to [ __ ]
see she just wanted to change the
neighborhood that's an episode so
kanye's saying i want to run for
president you're not concerned you're
going to retweet that you're dumb [ __ ]
yeah the fact she retweeted oh i thought
you were calling out
dumb [ __ ] yeah assertive
the fact that kim retweeted to me shows
that she's complicit in either his manic
episode or his
presidential election kim wants him to
be crazy she understands how the game
works
you think that her and her sister
they're both [ __ ] worth hundreds of
millions of dollars fist fighting on tv
you think they don't know exactly what
the [ __ ] is going on and they need
something to talk about every season
it has to be something giant life is
good i got kids everybody's happy
everybody got a kid everybody's cool let
me punch this [ __ ] to get some [ __ ]
ratings
snuffs that [ __ ] everything's good so
that's why if he's having an episode as
long as the [ __ ] is just entertaining
and it's bringing eyes they're cool with
it they don't
give a [ __ ] no but the moment it starts
[ __ ] up the bag once you start
talking
planned parenthood their bag matters
above all else
yeah but if he's calling planned
parenthood the devil and then all the
women who follow the kardashians they
will never stop fighting i know
somebody's made this joke before but we
have to talk about
has anybody ever gone there to planned
parenthood
you think anybody that you think a
couple that has a baby have gone in
there like
yeah we just want to start planning we
just want to know how the [ __ ] we're
supposed to do it
how we could do this planet parent or
paranoid effectively i think they'd do
that
but like it's probably in the same way
pablo escobar did community service you
know i mean like
did great how many [ __ ] things before
she robbed herself
how many of those apps did she sell the
[ __ ] kardashian chick
millions millions she made she made 40
million dollars off that she wouldn't
have known that she didn't try but you
got to try it
if i remember correctly one of the ways
that was a recent one she's making a lot
but
one of the ones that she made a ton a
ton of money on actually happened
through a legal battle where the people
created it then she wound up going after
him and then it became her
thing and i mean just it's amazing how
much money hey let me ask you a question
did it ever occur to you hearing that
story about her robbery in paris did you
have one inclination one moment where
you thought it was a setup
yes yeah i'm not saying it is
you know because they're suing everybody
that says anything but
i'm just saying that you can't help but
think when the girl
listen paris hilton before that green
anchor tv show came out conveniently
came out in a porno
having sex with a guy named rick solomon
that sold like crazy i mean
millions okay claims she never had any
ownership of it
came out two weeks before brought a lot
of publicity to the project
kardashian had there were two or three
things that didn't sound right
not uncle joey first of all
i would have punched her in the [ __ ]
head that's what i don't like
she didn't take a punch to the [ __ ]
head something's not right there
also they just picked her up and put her
in the bathroom not just that but they
tied her together with wrist you know
the
the plastic uh what do you call ties and
duct taped over them
okay your hands are tied now you're duct
taped over your feet too you're telling
me you got out of that
something isn't right i'm not saying
that she did or she didn't you know i
don't want her going after us
but this is coming to you from a [ __ ]
criminal and i'll tell you when you make
these kind of mistakes
this is a mistake
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
do
you know my wife watches that show with
the ladies there whose dad is now a
woman
and uh you know the ones out there in
california
you know the way they [ __ ] talk i was
sitting there
you know and this is this was a a
pivotal turning point
in me getting along better with my wife
was i just gave into reality tv
and i you know what i mean i just dialed
into my
[ __ ] inner caitlyn jenner and was
just like all right i'm going to [ __ ]
i'll feminine it up here right
i'll tuck the package between the
[ __ ]
i'll duct tape my balls and dick to my
taint for the next [ __ ]
hour and i will sit here and i will
watch this horse [ __ ]
so i'm watching it right and uh
the big one there as jay lawhead calls
her the power forward
of the kardashians all right she's
driving
the meerkat one and then the one who's
married to the [ __ ]
uh kanye west they always humble
kanye west right and uh they're driving
over
because she's trying to figure out you
know
if the [ __ ] whatever if the splooge
made it to the [ __ ]
hangar area sorry i'm not trying to get
all medical on you guys she's trying to
see if she's pregnant around what the
[ __ ] is going on
so they're driving to some suv they're
in wyoming right because that's what
rich people
in california do they eventually you
know want to pretend
that they're ranchers so they buy a big
they buy a spread out there in montana
or something
and long story short they're driving in
this [ __ ] suv
right the power forward's behind the
wheel as jay lawhead calls her
the meerkat is in the [ __ ] passenger
seat
and uh old sploogies in the back right
so they [ __ ] uh
it's snowing and this truck goes by
you know the truck has like the wind or
whatever you know as it goes by
so uh you know james worthy there is
[ __ ] you know whoa
going like what the [ __ ] and then they
keep talking and blah blah blah blah
and then another truck goes by and next
thing you know
she lost complete control of the car
and as it's spinning right the woman in
the back
i think she's pregnant so she's freaking
out oh she's got a baby there
a cute little baby is sitting there
you know reading the [ __ ] paper and
they start spinning
so the one in the back the mother is
going hey
[ __ ] uh you know orlando will rich
what the [ __ ]
what's going on and as they're spinning
the woman behind the
the [ __ ] wheel is going it's now i
fall it's not my fault it's how i fall
and they [ __ ] they spun into oncoming
traffic
luckily we're not hit right and then
they [ __ ] went off the road into a
ditch
and the big one
the captain captain [ __ ] kirk took no
responsibility whatsoever
it was just like you know and was
actually mad at old sploogie back there
because she was upset with her
she's gonna i i mean as i as shock came
by
as like when and it blew me into some
black ice
it's like no you were going too fast
you were driving too [ __ ] fast for
those conditions
you lost control of the car with your
niece in the car
you [ __ ] dope
[Music]
right and nobody held their feet to the
fire
nobody gave her any it's like you you
are a fuck-up
you know just standing there with your
[ __ ] back of your head touching the
top of your back trying to talk to her
get trying to get in a grill
right staring up from her navel looking
between her titties
seeing a half of two nostrils just
yelling at her hey you
[ __ ] up lady right none of them said
that
and then they just like that they're
[ __ ] just standing there going like
uh when my giant eight eight-foot sister
lost control out of the afa
it was like so
scary like they always like build up to
a [ __ ] point you're like yeah
and and and it's
always just like ha
when this meteor came down at our house
and it slammed in to the roof
above my bedroom and
for half a second i thought i was gonna
die i was like
so scared
so i am standing up
pacing in the living room now like a
[ __ ]
i don't know some [ __ ] pissed off
coach who's trying to stay inside the
coaches box so he doesn't get it
technical
and i'm [ __ ] screaming at the tv like
a bad call was made
completely forgot that i was gonna sit
there and try and get along with my wife
by watching this horseshit and i'm
yelling at the tv i'm like no you
[ __ ] eight foot [ __ ]
you [ __ ] up you were driving too fast
fast my
[ __ ] voice cracking you're driving
too fast man
your [ __ ] niece is in the car
right slow the [ __ ] down
you're driving a four-wheel drive
vehicle
you [ __ ] dope oh my god done with
that show
that was it i tried i lasted [ __ ] one
clip i'm done with that show
[ __ ] done with that show i [ __ ]
hate when people do [ __ ] like that
and people call them on like ah that's
what i'm talking about yeah it was your
fault
it is your fault stop being powerless
you [ __ ]
all right you have total control of that
[ __ ] situation you just drive a
little slower
you drive a little slower
um anyways
anyway i should be making fun of them
you know what they're going through
right now what they're having to deal
with
you know left is white black is my
up and down is black and white inside
out
and now bruce is [ __ ] caitlyn right
i really i really hold firm on that that
people cannot get upset
with anybody in that family if they're
still a little [ __ ] wigged out
that that their dad is now their mom you
know what i mean
just exactly what is the average
you know time it takes you know for you
to [ __ ] get your head around that
you know i don't know my wife sitting
there going oh he's showing his [ __ ]
titties to his kids it's just like
he's doing what i i mean i don't is that
true
if that's true i don't give a [ __ ]
that's just wrong on all kinds of levels
you know what i mean i know i get it i
get it you're coming back from the mall
and you got a little uh shoppers high
going on
and you want to show what you got but
they're tits
right when you were a guy did you take
your balls out and show them to
no you didn't you don't do that you
don't show
your sexual goods to your [ __ ] kids
and then compile it with new sexual
goods
right and it's not like new and improved
like hey i got my dick enlarged
no i [ __ ] uh
i got some tits now would you like to
see them
no dad i mean mom i wouldn't
jesus christ caitlyn can you put your
[ __ ] new tits away
is that asking too much you already took
all my rouge now you're going to take
your tits out
i mean i'm sitting in a car and i'm
chilling
away it was like sir
scott when you took your tips out dad it
was like that
sky i was right is my dad
taking his tits out right now i was like
bruce i mean kayla
i mean what the [ __ ]